a raid on the offices of the president's
personal attorney would have to clear a
number of legal hurdles before a judge
allowed it
Jeff big aids is at FBI headquarters in
Washington with the implications of this
action against Michael Cohen Jeff good
morning good morning CBS News has
confirmed that a referral from Special
Counsel Robert Muller led to these
search warrants targeting Michael Cohen
and investigators found emails financial
documents and some client communications
possibly involving President Trump
we're told that Cohen is under
investigation for possible bank fraud
campaign finance violations and other
potential crimes connected to the 2016
election Cohen paid a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars to porns to our stormy
Daniels who allege that she had an
affair with President Trump but he is
also under scrutiny in connection with
the Russia investigation in a statement
Cohen's attorney blasted the search
warrants and seizures calling them
completely inappropriate and unnecessary
adding that these tactics are wrong
because mr. Cohen has cooperated fully
with the investigation but the search
warrants and the way that these raids
unfolded suggest otherwise that
investigators the federal prosecutors
and the FBI disagree because they
swooped in yesterday to take control of
potential evidence
John Jeff thanks and swoopin they did